[Music]
you are watching the press preview a
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive in the next half hour
we'll see what's making tomorrow's
headlines with guardian columnist
williams and the sun on sunday's
political editor kate ferguson bell that
be with us now and again at half past
eleven so let's see what's on some of
those front pages for you now
well tomorrow's eye raises concerns
about debt that households may run to
pay for energy bills reporting that 1.7
million households have already or are
considering cancelling energy direct
debits
on express reports national grid bosses
plan to offer rebates to households for
turning off their washing machines
during early evening peak hours
the telegraph's top story is on nhs 111
callers waiting 20 times longer than
they should be with some patients
reporting being left on hold for up to
an hour
while the male is also leading on a
health story a new drug being trialled
by the nhs that could prevent a tenth of
cancer deaths
guardian reports that basic needs to
care home residents aren't being met
because of a lack of staff
while the time says boris johnson is
still more popular with tory voters than
either candidate to replace him as prime
minister and that's where she soon act
all his trust
the ft leads on russian diplomat gennady
gastilov dismissing chances of a peace
deal with ukraine
while the metro reports boxing star
tyson fury's calls for a crackdown on
knife crime following his cousin's death
by stabbing
that's also the top story in the sun
and something slightly different from
the daily star reporting an influx of
wasps from germany to the uk
and a reminder that by scanning the qr
code you'll see on screen during the
programme you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's newspapers while you
watch us
and we are joined tonight by zoe
williams columnist at the guardian and
kate ferguson the son on sunday's
political editor welcome to you both let
us start with the telegraph and their
front page story on nhs 111 the fact
that callers
are being left on hold for 20 times
longer than is the uh expected time zoe
it it's an unsurprising story if you
think about the wider crisis in the nhs
right so you've got a e bosses saying
don't go to a e unless you absolutely
have to which is an extremely difficult
call to make as a private individual you
it it's really not that easy to triage
yourself
um then you've got the crisis in
ambulances if you do go into a e you've
got the crisis in paramedics arriving at
the scene if you need an ambulance and
now this kind of gatekeeper service the
one that's meant to protect
the more acute care from people who
could be cared for over the phone
also in crisis so it's really a signal
of this not being any kind of isolated
problem but rather
you know
absolute chaos across the piece
which is fundamentally the result of
having been followed out and underfunded
for a large number of years yes i mean
it does seem in recent days and actually
longer than that we have been seeing
story after story um talking of of uh
resources being pushed within the the
nhs and this is the latest in the long
list
yeah it is i mean i think whoever the
next prime minister is there's two big
crises
awaiting them one is obviously the
energy crisis which i'm sh and of course
of living crisis which i'm sure we'll
speak about later but the first is this
nhs crisis so as i was saying we're
seeing the nhs under strain across all
areas so currently you know paramedics
can't the hospitals are social to beds
that you've got paramedics in ambulances
queuing up
trying to admit to their patient they
can't which is why you're seeing these
really long um ambulance waiting times
and now this one one one triage service
also under massive pressure so as the
story says today you're meant to get a
call back within you're meant to get
your aunt your call answered sorry
within 20 seconds
and the average now is six and a half
minutes people waiting hours sometimes
to have the call answered
i think um
this is before winter even hit right so
this is the middle of the summer it's
meant to be a relatively
calm period for the nhs and they start
gearing up preparing for the winter
crisis but that they're already under
such massive strain gives us i think a
bit of a
flavor of just how bad things are going
to get this winter and a huge question
for the next prime minister of what
you're going to do about it some people
will say we need to go on a hiring
stream of doctors nurses medics
internationally we did a interview with
liz trust on the summit sunday over the
weekend and she was talking about maybe
signing up for sort of dad's army of um
retired medics to come back to the front
line of the nhs like we saw in covid we
will certainly see some kind of movement
around that i think but whether or not
that you have those people in the books
to actually plug the shortfall in
staffing is yet to be seen
so let's move on to the eye and more on
the cost of living debt crisis and
people's worries over energy bills liz
trust promising more help for households
but no specifics
well to be honest this was liz trust's
promise is actually in kate's interview
so she could probably speak better to
just how precise trust was prepared to
be
are my hunches that she's doing the
exact
opposite of what any strategist would
tell her to do which is that you know at
the moment the only plan on the table is
labor saying just freeze them at the
current rates nobody can afford any more
she has three options she either ignores
that altogether and lets 40 million
british people slide into fuel poverty
which is un is astronomical um or she
just rolls over and says yes
let's do stalma's plan and pretend it's
my plan which is not unheard of in the
conservative party but it's not a great
start or she does this
slightly weak
meeting him almost halfway nobody's
really sure how far she's prepared to
meet him and frankly it has set a bit of
a challenge for them because anything
less than a completely frozen bill at
the current levels is going to really be
problematic
you know because people are going to say
well it doesn't
freezing it at a thousand pounds more a
year doesn't actually help me i don't
have any more so anything it's really
really difficult
situation to be in but i think coming
out with these very kind of piecemeal
weak
inconclusive
vague plans is probably the worst of all
possible options but as i say it's
kate's interview so maybe she said
something
you know maybe maybe you can give more
kind of context
kate do you have any further insight as
to the the means and the ways that she
might be proposing to to help families
more
well obviously britain's facing this
huge cost of living crisis i think we
had one estimate yesterday that
the energy price cap could hit 6 000
pounds next year it's currently 2 000
going to go up to i think 3 200 gives
you a sense of just how
big a crisis how much those bills are
ratcheting up by now liz trust
throughout the campaign has said look
i'm going to cut taxes and that's
twofold she's saying that cutting taxes
will finally kickstart our economy and
get us growing again and also it will
help a bit with your energy bills she's
it seems that realistically she knows
she's got to do more and when i spoke to
her in nursing on sunday this weekend
she says she was looking across the
board of what helps she can give and
hinted heavily that families will get
more help and also businesses who are
struggling with those spiraling energy
costs but she does not and i think
probably will not tell us any more
details before she safely got those keys
to number 10 in her pocket
interestingly at the same time as this
the treasury is working up proposals and
the big question for the treasury is
how much money does the next prime
minister want to spend and so how
targeted should the support be or how
broad brush both rishi and liz have
talked about wanting to give more
targeted support the big question is
is that going to be enough when bills
are just going up so so so much and
really i think the treasury are looking
at all options on the table short of
nationalizing the energy companies so
from beefing up benefits a bit to doing
something maybe a bit more universal
like topping up the rishi sunak plan um
and we had a story yesterday about one
particularly kind of i guess radical
proposal which would see gps prescribe
money off your energy bills basically
the thing the treasury you're grappling
with is
how big do you go how much money do you
want to spend and therefore how
universal should it be and
that's the question for the next prime
minister really because it comes with a
massive price yeah meanwhile just so
we'll we'll move on we'll fit this in
before the break meanwhile in the times
we read that the cost of uk households
of bailing out nationalized energy
retailer uh bulb is expected to sort of
more than four billion by the spring
unless the government achieves a sale
zoe
i mean this is a classic ft story
actually because it's quite it's quite
technically complex you know the reason
is the reason it's spiraling so much is
that once the once the company is
nationalized there are laws against
hedging against price increases but
everybody knows the price increases are
going to happen so they can't actually
build those price increases into the
valuation of the company or the
profitability of the company even though
the prices are obvious because that's
against the law so they've got so
instead they're kind of
kind of you know
holding this
bulb um
retailer up not knowing whether
anybody's gonna buy it now i mean this
is it it's a really interesting
situation because everybody talks as
though the only thing a government can
do
is at the retailer level right so they
can either fund price caps at a certain
level they can fund price gaps but let
off gem set the level they can freeze
the price cap and spend 60 billion
keeping it frozen or they can
nationalize and have this terrible
bailout bill which you know similar to
what happened with rbs
and anything anything other than that is
much too radical to contemplate so
looking at the actual wholesaler looking
at the production of gas looking at the
production of energy and having any
government intervention in that
is just too rich for the kind of
discourses blood if you like but
actually the reason that if there isn't
in france energy bills are going up by
four percent and here they're going up
by what they're going up by is because
they had the difficult conversations
about the source of the energy not just
the retailer of the energy okay zoe and
cake for the moment thank you we're
going to take a break
coming up the daily mail lead with a new
blood test trialled by the nhs that
could reportedly stop one in ten cancer
deaths stay with us
[Music]
welcome back you're watching the press
preview still with me zoe williams
economist at the guardian and the sun on
sunday's political editor kate ferguson
let us take a look at uh the mail um and
this um astonishing story
potentially very very good news a new
blood test that could stop one in ten
cancer deaths being trialled
take us into this story kate
yeah this um it's been described in the
piece as the holy grail potentially of
spotting cancer early so it's this big
trial that's being launched in the nhs
which can apparently this can it can
spot cancers before symptoms show so we
all know that it's so important to catch
cancer early and by the time people
present
specific particularly at the moment
where you know we've just talked earlier
about the crisis in our nhs that big
covered backlog was still getting
through lots of people not presenting
early enough so this this test seems to
be able to detect one in ten cancers
um and if there's some stats in the
piece about how if it was rolled out
nationwide it could save hundreds of
thousands of lives now it's we should
point out it's quite early in the um in
the trials but it seems that it's it's
incredibly kind of optimistic news and a
real breakthrough in science
yes uh
possibly uh if all goes successfully
with the trials it could be rolled out
to as early as
2024 but
they're suggesting that it could save
around 16 000 lives a year zoe
well
i'm sorry to sound a note of caution and
obviously i want a cure for cancer as
much as the next man but i've been in
this game such a long time and i've seen
the daily mail run cure for cancer
stories about so many things you know
tomatoes cure cancer
being thinner cures cancer it you they
they they just seem it i feel like it's
their out of office auto reply of a
front page and this blood test is still
at trial stage and i don't even think
the medics behind it or the
pharmaceutical companies behind it would
make the claims that the daily mail is
making so i'm just i don't want to be a
cassandra i'm just saying it hasn't
always worked out the way the male
thinks it will with cancer although it
does say hundreds are taking part in the
trial of 140 000 volunteers are already
being referred for a scan or
colonoscopy get my words out as a result
of the test findings and it's expected
around half of those referred could have
cancer so it does seem to be in motion
zoe and showing very positive signs
it's
it's a gigantic scale study and a very
welcome one i'm just not sure that i'm
going to take one in ten cancer deaths
okay
we shall see we shall see uh final story
uh this is a sad story and tyson fury
calling
for intervention in uh knife crime this
is uh following the death of his cousin
who was stabbed to death in the street
in altering him
kate
yeah i mean this is obviously a horrible
and grim story a 31 year old man tyson
fury's cousin stabbed to death in a um
outside a pub in in greater manchester i
think it it raises a broader point
though doesn't it tyson fury today
saying we enough is enough we need to
get tougher on knife crimes he's calling
for a much tougher sentencing and i
think this raises a more broader issue
which is we are seeing violent crimes
spike massively across
not just cities but the whole country
and this is a sort of big issue rumbling
along in the background we haven't
actually seen the leadership candidates
talk too much about crime it's not been
at the top of the agenda given the cost
of living crisis the nhs crisis but
among voters when you look at polls or
when you sit in on focus groups which
i've done a lot of as you can imagine in
the last few weeks you can see this is
incredibly high up there they're very
important to people indeed we must leave
it there sorry kate and zoe wishes